[Music]
Can Dr. Pete elaborate on a bioenergetic view of sex determination during embryonic development?
Would the mother's hormonal environment play a big role in the process?
Yeah, yeah. Temperature hormones, stress hormones in particular,
in fish and reptiles and birds even,
the temperature is very essential to developing the sex ratio.
It depends on temperature, right? Like alligators, when they lay eggs, if it's hot, it's mostly males?
Yeah, and chickens, the same thing. Early in the season, I forget which way it is,
but it's a balance that's beneficial to have lots of females relative to males
when conditions are going to be optimal.
Do you think the high ratio of females to males, do you think that nature is essentially
a protective mechanism to the species? I mean, protecting the species from disappearing if the environment is not good,
it's better to have more females than males because one male can essentially ensure the continuation,
but if you have an equal amount or more males, it becomes more difficult to reproduce.
Yeah, I think so. Interesting. Okay, another one here.
So as an extension, the recent statistics that we're seeing all over the world,
that a lot more girls are being born, aside from endocrine disruptors that are known to be estrogenic,
and that can cause it, could it also be a sign that the conditions are deteriorating in our environment
and the human race basically is producing more women in order to have a higher chance of survival?
That sounds very reasonable.
You just reminded me of something. Would that IQ drop of kids that were born in 2020,
I mean, is this going to result in a profoundly stupid society in the next 10, 20 years?
Yeah, there was a, have you read Ernest Sternglass's books or articles?
He studied the effects of radiation on miscarriages and the ratio of boys surviving and so on.
He shows that at the peak atmospheric contamination from the 1963 bomb competition,
the atmospheric testing of nuclear bombs, 18 years later, the academic scores of all sorts,
what's the standard exam at high school?
Anyway, the average score went down and the genetic people said that's because more poor people are taking the test.
But he showed very clearly that looking at just the highest scoring portion of the population,
that the greatest decrease 18 years after the radiation peak,
the greatest decrease was in the highest scoring category.
So it lowered the average, but it even more drastically knocked out the exceptionally competent kids of that age.
You've read about the, they call it the Flynn effect, right?
The rising IQ scores throughout most of the 20th century, then in the 90s they plateaued,
and after 2000 they've been steadily dropping.
Even though some countries show lately that the ratio of the brain to the body weight and height has decreased in several countries.
Would these develop countries or?
Germany was one of them.
Oh wow.
Not even accounting for the indefinite mRNA vaccines, these kids are going to have to deal with them.
Okay, here's another one. Are Sheldrake's morphic fields and Vernadsky's noosphere the same thing?
Yeah, they could be. The general optimistic view of reality is connecting them and behind them.
That the universe itself is conscious in some intentional way.
Vernadsky said in the midst of the ending of the second world war, he was surrounded by destruction and death,
but he said he was confident that the world would find a way out of it by increasing its metabolic rate, accumulating carbon dioxide,
warming things up, making brains get bigger, making plants grow faster, everything working more intensely.
And the noosphere idea is the basic thing that we're all headed in that direction just because of the nature of the universe.
Did Russian science incorporate Vernadsky's geocosmic realism into their thinking?
Yeah, a large part of the establishment did.
There were the dogmatic, I think of them as the Hegelian Marxists, the ones that thought the dialectic was some mysterious thing.
But the average intelligent, well-read Russian biologist and scientist in general had that sort of an emergence orientation
that it's part of the Marxist meaning of the dialectic, but it goes with an optimistic view of what the cosmos is all about.
Amazing, thank you for that. Give me a second here.
Okay, Ray has previously mentioned how our ruling class damaged art in the 20th century and highlighted the creation of Rockefeller ghost art.
If a counterculture painting movement was to start today, what themes, styles, or subjects would Ray like to see captured or communicated?
Many thanks from Australia.
I think a little bit of the realism of Franz Hall's perceiving interesting things in people, anything that is a worthwhile insight about the nature of people and their interactions.
Franz Hall was very confident at capturing such things.
Did you mention him in General of Energy in 1994? You said that it's more alive, his paintings.
They were not just a static, boring view of the person, or they reflected something about their personality?
Yeah, he could perceive intensely enough that he could capture instantaneous things that represented much more of a person than a photograph would have.
His paintings, you can easily see that when you're looking at his paintings.
Okay, we'll wrap it up here very soon. Does Ray think starch is responsible for a change in personality towards war and conquer that has caused the atrocities since the beginning of agriculture?
It goes with malnutrition. The high starch diets end up tending to be deficient in some of the essential nutrients.
High phosphate, stress-inducing things that make people irritable, and a high serotonin outcome of the inflammatory diet.
Great stuff. And Georgie, interrupt me at any point here. Just a few more here.
What is the cost of getting drunk occasionally, like Blackout, passed out in the front yard naked drunk? Like five times a year, not financially, but on your health and longevity.
I think it's very stressful to lose consciousness.
Maybe you told somebody in email a long time ago that it greatly depletes your liver glycogen and it would take multiple days to recover.
That's my experience. Like drinking is never worth it because I'll feel so awful the next few days.
And so it just affects some people more than others based on their ability to store liver glycogen, do you think?
Yeah, I think so.
Wouldn't taking a hefty dose of progesterone largely replicate the effects of getting drunk?
It increases your ability to store glycogen, so it doesn't have any long-term negative effects. But when I accidentally overdosed on it, and coordination of my hands and feet was impossible for a while.
But when I deliberately took a very large amount because I had a bad migraine, I went with the euphoria, simply went to sleep in about two minutes and had no more headache.
But when it comes on accidentally, you should be able to use your hands and feet. It's embarrassing.
Okay, let me just do one more advertisement, then we'll close out the show here.
Okay, so you can purchase Ray's newsletter for $30 for 12 issues over three years, four times a year.
You can purchase his books at Ray Peet's by emailing raypeetsnewsletter@gmail.com.
And then if you want to purchase progesterone, progeste, specifically from Keenogen, email katharine@keenogen@gmail.com.
Each bottle contains 3,400 milligrams of progesterone.
And then Ray, again, people hate when I ask you to speculate, but what do you think we're in store for in 2022?
I think the resistors are going to put up more and more resistance, but Bill Gates has already said that people are working on a vaccine for the Marburg hemorrhagic fever virus,
which is similar to the Ebola virus and kills up to 90% of the people it infects.
And he says that is likely to be the next epidemic.
And since they are about ready to have a vaccine for it, I think he might be right.
As soon as a vaccine is able to come to market at a profit of half a trillion dollars, then we can have the Marburg epidemic.
But I think the resistance is gaining faster than the clever World Economic Forum schemers can dream up catastrophes to happen to us.
But if this Marburg virus, if it's so deadly, just like Ebola, then it can't really be a pandemic because it's going to kill most of the host before it has a chance to spread, right?
How would you have a pandemic with that?
It's just scarier.
And that's all that's needed is to have a vaccine that is going to save everyone.
And all it has to do is kill a few dozen people that they didn't want anyway.
And then they can sell a trillion dollars worth of vaccines.
And that will probably be much more easy to mandate because they'll be look, this is truly deadly.
Don't resist because COVID is nothing compared to this.
But you're saying they could actually release something harmful, not like COVID being a mild type of thing.
And but this actually being harmful.
And since so many people have caught on that don't want the vaccine and realize that the vaccine mortality goes up the first month after being vaccinated higher than not receiving a vaccine, that awareness is getting out.
So they need something really to scare people, show people bleed bleeding out of their eyes and ears and a real horror show.
Well, yeah, that would do it.
And so this second act, you think it was strategic in making it even more gruesome?
Yeah, I think that's why they're interested in.
OK, well, we have that look to look forward to in 2020.
Very, very excited about that.
OK, Ray, I see on the line, guys, thank you so much for hanging out.
Sincerely appreciate this year.
Other than being a total horror show, I've had fun doing this podcast and Georgie and Ray, you guys always make it really special.
And this these have been my anchor this year of doing these.
Sincerely appreciate all the viewership. And you guys are just a great, great audience.
And you guys always give positive feedback. And so sincerely appreciate it.
So, Georgie Dinkoff, thank you so much. And Ray, thank you so much.
Just it's been really incredible. And I can't wait to continue to do it in 2022.
So, Ray, stay on the line and guys have a safe weekend.
We'll talk to you guys soon and have a good New Year's and peace out.
Bye everyone.
[Music]